Il termine musica.
Musica deriva dal greco mousikè, l'arte delle muse.
Si riferisce all'arte di combinare più
suoni in base a regole definite,
diverse a seconda dei luoghi e delle epoche.
Ma non basta un insieme, seppure armonioso, di suoni
per dar vita alla musica. La musica nasce, cresce e si sviluppa
all'interno di un determinato contesto sociale
e diviene manifestazione dello stesso.
Musica e rumore, anticamente, erano visti come due cose contrapposte
la musica non poteva contenere il rumore
e il rumore non poteva contenere musica.
Anticamente perché, esattamente un secolo fa, qui a Milano, nel 1913,
Luigi Russolo creerà sei famiglie di strumenti,
sei famiglie di strumenti detti intonarumori.
Con questi strumenti, Russolo creerà delle composizioni
fatte unicamente di rumore,
il rumore di una città, il rumore del tram, il rumore dell'aereo,
il rumore del treno, il rumore di Milano.
(Risveglio di una città, 1914, di Luigi Russolo)
All'esperienza di Russolo, seguiranno diversi artisti
che cominceranno ad inserire nelle proprie composizioni il rumore.
Quindi misceleranno musica e rumore:
Edgar Varèse, George Antheil, Pierre Schaeffer, padre della musica concreta,
cercando sempre un equilibrio tra i due elementi.
Ma nel secondo dopoguerra
si inserirà un nuovo elemento che è il silenzio.
Il silenzio tenderà a staccare i suoni,
a staccare i suoni relativi alla musica e i suoni relativi al rumore.
Oppure ci saranno artisti che daranno voce al silenzio,
in particolare John Cage nel 1952.
John Cage si siederà a un pianoforte,
lo chiuderà,
farà partire un cronometro, 4 minuti e 33 secondi,
che è il titolo della sua composizione,
e rimarrà in silenzio.
La composizione non sarà fatta di silenzio,
bensì sarà fatta dai suoni provenienti dalla sala,
il colpo di tosse, il bisbiglio...
Nella sua prima esibizione c'era la pioggia,
quindi il rumore del vento, il rumore del temporale.
[John Cage, 4' 33'']
[Primo Movimento]
Gli artisti del secondo Dopoguerra cercheranno sempre di spingersi più avanti,
cercando sempre nuovi equilibri in queste composizioni
e, a partire dagli anni '60, con la nascita del genere Rock, vi saranno artisti,
come Jimmy Hendrix, che inseriranno nelle proprie composizioni
la distorsione della chitarra elettrica
che può essere intesa sia come rumore che come suono.
Oppure Frank Zappa cercherà di mixare,
all'interno delle proprie composizioni, diversi generi musicali,
dal jazz, al rock, alla musica classica.
Ma proprio a partire dagli anni '60 e col genere rock,
la musica avrà sempre più, in maniera significativa,
il senso di un veicolo di comunicazione.
Gli artisti di quel periodo cercheranno di trasmettere, con la musica, dei messaggi al proprio pubblico.
E il pubblico considererà la musica come un mezzo di aggregazione e di scambio di idee.
In particolare, qui vediamo una foto di Woodstock,
proprio in quel periodo cominceranno anche ad essere utilizzati
degli strumenti nuovi, strumenti che permetteranno al compositore,
all'artista, di inserire suoni relativi,
come fece Russolo appena 60 anni prima,
relativi all'ambiente socioeconomico o socioculturale in cui essi vivevano.
Ad esempio, i Pink Floyd inseriranno nelle proprie composizioni
i suoni delle monetine o della cassa, come nel brano "Money"
oppure inseriranno suoni relativi al tempo.
[Pink Floyd, Money]
Attraverso queste nuove strumentazioni,
come il campionatore o il sintetizzatore,
gli artisti avranno a disposizione degli strumenti, appunto,
che gli permetteranno di controllare e modulare il suono e di creare nuovi suoni.
Nasceranno anche nuovi generi.
Per esempio i Kraftwerk daranno vita a quel filone,
che troviamo ancora tutt'oggi, che è quello della musica elettronica.
E vi saranno artisti che negli anni '80, utilizzando questi suoni,
inseriranno, come aveva fatto Russolo, appunto, in precedenza,
dei suoni relativi al loro periodo, come hanno fatto gli Art of Noise,
che riprendono proprio il nome da Russolo e che sentiamo in questa esibizione
[Art of Noise, Moments in love]
Il sound degli anni '80 verrà invaso da queste nuove sonorità
e gli artisti che partiranno da questo periodo e andranno avanti,
come ad esempio i Depeche Mode,
cambieranno il proprio sound nel corso degli anni,
grazie anche alle nuove strumentazioni e ai nuovi suoni
che verranno ricondotti nelle loro composizioni.
[Depeche Mode]
Come abbiamo detto, però, la musica è la fotografia della società.
Così come essa si sta trasformando in questi anni,
anche l'ambiente socioculturale e socioeconomico
ha delle significative trasformazioni.
Pensate che negli anni '80 vi è il passaggio
dall'epoca industriale a quella postindustriale,
in particolare in Inghilterra, grazie anche
alla spinta tatcheriana. E proprio in Inghilterra
vi sarà l'abbandono di intere fabbriche e capannoni
che verranno lasciati soli, abbandonati,
fino a quando negli anni '90,
o meglio, alla fine degli anni '80, dei giovani
entreranno in questi capannoni per fare delle feste,
per farci dei concerti, il periodo Rave Industrial
quindi, per dare vita a questi capannoni con i suoni che li avevano prima riempiti,
utilizzando anche dei materiali che venivano utilizzati nell'industria
lamiere, barre di ferro, copertoni o materiale riciclato.
[Musica Rave Industrial]
Siamo a circa un secolo dall'esperienza di Russolo
e in ambito comunicativo si fa sempre più strada
l'utilizzo delle immagini associate al suono.
In particolare, nel 2002 vi sarà una crew inglese,
I Ninja Tune
e, all'interno della stessa, un gruppo chiamato Coldcut
che metterà in piedi uno strumento tale per cui riescono ad abbinare
e mettere a tempo immagini e suoni.
Questo strumento verrà utilizzato per la prima volta
in una esibizione al Beaubourg di Parigi
e successivamente nel 2006, in una audio live performance
portata in giro per il mondo, loro
faranno conoscere al loro pubblico questo brano, Timber,
con il quale porteranno al loro pubblico la problematica della deforestazione
della foresta amazzonica, in questo modo.
[Coldcut, Timber]
Questa è un'immagine tratta proprio dal loro live
quindi, nel loro live loro si esibivano
sia utilizzando il suono, sia mettendo a tempo l'immagine
questo per un'ora e 30 di concerto.
Inoltre, il suono diventa sempre più significativo
e indentificativo di un qualcosa.
Se in precedenza, nel periodo di Russolo,
era il rumore che andava a contraddistinguere un oggetto,
a partire dall'anno 2000, si fa sempre più la strada in cui
è l'oggetto ad essere contraddistinto da un suono.
Esempio A, Jurassic Park 3, 2001,
dove il pubblico riconoscerà con chiarezza
il suono di un cellulare. Ma non di un cellulare qualsiasi,
di una marca ben precisa.
[Jurassic Park 3, 2001]
Questo per quanto riguarda il cinema,
ma anche nel campo automobilistico, si è prestata molta attenzione
al suono delle auto.
In particolare, una piccola casa automobilistica italiana,
Pagani, nel 2012 ha prodotto una macchina,
la Huayra, una macchina da 700 cavalli,
con un motore bi-turbo. Siccome il motore turbo
non ha un motore così piacevole per gli appassionati di queste vetture,
che apprezzano di più il suono di un motore aspirato,
hanno coinvolto degli ingegneri del suono inglesi che,
assieme agli ingegneri tedeschi,
hanno modificato la sagomatura degli scarichi
per dare un rumore diverso all'auto.
Ma, altro esempio è la Tesla Roadster.
La Tesla produce macchine elettriche.
In questo modello del 2009, la Tesla monterà
nella parte posteriore dell'auto, due altoparlanti
per dare un suono all'auto. Che suono ha dato?
Ha dato il suono di un motore V8, o il suono da guerre stellari.
Che senso ha dare a una macchina un suono da guerre stellari?
Soprattutto a una macchina così evoluta dal punto di vista meccanico e tecnico,
quale può essere una macchina elettrica?
Le case automobilistiche sono molto attente
ai dettagli sonori.
Pensate solamente alle strumentazioni di bordo.
Ogni macchina ha il proprio suono.
Oppure al suono delle strumentazioni meccaniche,
la chiusura di una porta.
Oppure al suono relativo alla comunicazione, il sound logo.
Audi ha cambiato per 3 volte in 14 anni il proprio sound logo, facendolo evolvere in questo modo.
[Sound Logo Audi]
Questa è l'evoluzione del termine suono.
Ma, attualmente, vi è sempre più l'attenzione
all'abbinamento tra suono e immagine.
Ciò non è sempre efficace ed efficiente.
Pensate a degli spot televisivi.
Molte volte ricordate il motivo o la marca,
ma non ricordate il prodotto o il messaggio promozionale.
Eppure vi sono artisti che riescono a coniugare perfettamente suono e immagine,
dando al pubblico un effetto come questo
[Amon Tobin, Isam Live. World Premiere MUTEK - Montreal - Giugno 2011]
E in pochissimi casi vengono utilizzati anche nell'ambito della comunicazione.
Deadmau5, un paio di anni fa, per il lancio
del Nokia Lumia a Londra, ha fatto questo spettacolo incredibile,
coinvolgendo l'intera città, in questo modo.
[Deadmau5, evento Lancio Nokia Lumia 800]
2013. 100 anni dall'esperienza di Russolo.
Cos'è cambiato?
Nel periodo di Russolo vi era l'arte del rumore,
oggi abbiamo l'arte del suono,
siamo ormai invasi dai suoni e lo saremo sempre di più.
E' necessario razionalizzare, organizzarli,
puntare, ad esempio, a mettere ordine in questo universo selvaggio sonoro
anche utilizzando risorse interne al nostro Paese,
80.000 autori, ad esempio, 2.000 editori. Noi abbiamo una storia millenaria.
Quindi, ripartendo dall'esperienza di Russolo,
e facendo perno su quell'esperienza, ripartire,
dare nuovo slancio a questa nuova attività di
organizzazione del suono, lavorare sullo stesso
e lasciare da parte ormai la vecchia esperienza
legata al rumore, per ripartire in una nuova esperienza legata al suono.
Come? Come hanno fatto tutti gli artisti che hanno seguito Russolo.
Credendo nel mix.
[Applauso]
Grazie